pour cette balade en chiens de traîneau
dans le massif du jura
ces deux touristes en provenance de la
région parisienne ont eu beaucoup de
chance j'ai regardé un petit peu les
autres activités que je pouvais faire et
comme je n'avais jamais fait de chiens
de traîneaux je me suis penché dessus et
j'ai réussi à trouver un créneau pour le
faire donc j'ai sauté sur l'occasion
pas de remontées mécaniques cette année
alors pour celles et ceux qui se
laissent du ski de fond des raquettes
il faut trouver une nouvelle activité à
faire en couple ou en famille est
compatible avec les restrictions liées à
la cobi 19
étant donné le contexte sanitaire et
puis on avait besoin d'évasion donc on a
décidé de prendre la route pour aller
dans le jura ses proches de chez nous
vers dijon
c'est vrai qu'avec le traîneau c'était
fort d'inertes découvrir des paysages
pareil c'est nous n'aurions pas le faire
autrement je pense beaucoup se sont rués
vers les chiens de traîneau à tel point
qu'il est aujourd'hui presque impossible
de trouver un créneau libre avec un
musher florent joli bois qui
transportent des touristes sur son
traîneau depuis dix ans n'avait jamais
vu un tel engouement pour son activité
des réservations le calendrier est
quasiment en plein jusque la fin de
l'hiver c'est beaucoup plus important
que les années précédentes à sauf que
peut pas nous augmenter notre activité
on a toujours même nombre de chiens on
va pas les faire courir plus par respect
pour eux alors en ce moment on a 100 150
appels téléphoniques des fois par jour
koala plus haut plus de mails des sms
etc et il faut s'armer de courage pour
réussir à contacter un musher dans le
haut doubs les compagnies de balades en
chiens de traîneaux sont tellement
sollicités qu'elles n'ont même plus le
temps de répondre au téléphone